what you really really want you said
that there were points in your career as
a Spice Girl you turned into a robot
someone who no longer expressed emotions
thoughts or ideas what exactly was
silencing you yeah you know something
happens quite early on in the the Spice
Girls journey and you know I have a
little bit of a Fallout with Victoria
and
I was threatened to get kicked out of
the band
and it freaked me out and I was like I
have to control myself
[Music]
I also found it interesting that it was
difficult for you sometimes to embrace
being a sporty spies and really owning
that nickname the aesthetic that we were
led to believe in the 90s it was very
thin the pressure started to mount on
uncertain comments by certain people it
became a little bit of a trigger it
escalated into quite a serious eating
disorder in her new Memoir the sporty
one My Life as a Spice Girl out now the
48 year old sheds Light On the Dark Side
of Fame and reveals what the girls were
really like behind the scenes we drive
each other nuts don't get me wrong
but we love each other
you write in the book that the band is
not broken up so what gives when are we
reuniting again right yeah well you
don't have to ask me twice and I mean
I'm so excited we constantly talk about
getting back on stage is it going to be
our five of you will it be four we're
talking four at the moment and Victoria
the the offer is always there right
she's always invited but you know it
will happen we will get back on stage
together
[Music]